[Music]
in royal makeover news this was
submitted by said it and forget it
a Russian billionaire gave his childhood
school a fairytale makeover how cute I
didn't know Russian billionaires did
charity or maybe you did for his own
selfish I hate how I always think of
that exactly or I think about I'm like
oh you're a billionaire and you only
made over one school [ __ ] you oh it's
terrible really good Russian billionaire
you must be a like some kind of shady
mafia guy or some oil tycoon and you
have nothing else going there what's
wrong with me that I was like wow that's
really nice I remember there's something
some kind of tragedy happens and ie some
tragedy how give people benefit of the
doubt most people don't like you guys in
most people like by you here you know
one thing like everyone wants to kind of
like take a shot at it because I can't
Kardashian this or a carnie or whatever
you know this Jill Steve Bill Gates is
your uncle okay let's say it's your
wedding day you open the card from Uncle
Bill yeah he gave me a hundred bucks it
gives you three grand
oh yeah that's a lot that sucks he's a
billionaire yes you see I'm not entitled
to his money no it's not about being
entitled to his money I'm like you gave
me what is literally not even a dime to
you yeah you could giving you zero Lea
no give me the hundred dollar thing to
you that's what I say about Bill Gates
only for the billionaire Kendrick Lamar
about his sister like this a loaded
Toyota Camry when she graduated high
school
Tamra got sick he's like she can't
afford the maintenance on the bed I get
our business he's gonna have the afford
thing I did that was my mom what about
our beans yeah but then I got her a
purse and I wanted to get her a designer
purse this is something that she would
never get herself mmm but because she
still lives in the hood I didn't want
something that would attract a lot of
attention so instead of hitting her like
an LV I got her what a JanSport
[Laughter]
nobody like you have to be in two brands
to know Ferragamo you're like their dumb
asses won't know what this is
dumb asses but they yes altered swine
right it's why I won't know salvatore
ferragamo yeah it's just a Gino Poletti
Agha I've heard of that Valentina I've
heard of that yeah but because she's in
the hood I was afraid that they're gonna
shock her because they're like oh she
has I'll be print yeah they were Jack's
watch they all know what Ferragamo is
taking here's my thing with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the Jasper cuz we haven't
gotten to the story so I don't know
they're gonna say his name or anything
like that but my thing is like I was
just watching HLN news and this guy
bought 100 generators to send to the
Bahamas the Bahamas right if somebody
tried to take a picture of them and Nike
here this face cuz he's not doing it for
that reason
yeah alright when I see rappers like
going to schools and giving the kids
backpacks are like that's cool but it's
like who you're doing it for it's like
all the vloggers I give money to
homeless you know I'm gonna do something
good the world's got a [ __ ] no no I
feel like that is when I'm leaving
something in the tip jar and the person
steps away from register hey hey hey hey
look this is for the axe the [ __ ]
syrup in that vente okay I don't care
about it like I don't know if I do
charity I'm not doing it for a keepsake
in for a memory I'm doing it because I
wanted to give out of the goodness I
just watch my father-in-law did that of
the wedding we were there getting free
drinks and [ __ ] and the bartender turns
around to pour the drinks and he's
already got the money out and he's like
waiting and then as soon as it around
he's like does he do this [ __ ] yeah
we did that
thank you this is a medium strip love
those like I want you to see I'm gonna
just be throwing this while you begged
over twerking I bring your kitties here
or kept happening me at one point where
I was like the only way to do make sure
that they watch is like I tip in ten
dollar world as a quarter so that way
they feel it oh yeah yeah you gonna feel
it when I thought is that your back pull
your thumb now and I've done it like
stuffing into thud oh those balls that
yeah but you know if she do you have to
stuff it at her [ __ ] so she holds it in
there get the other roll spent stuffing
in her [ __ ] pants that one she goes
into the back room and she's got [ __ ]
crutches and bands all over and like
what happened he's like some guy made a
Rain Man you don't even [ __ ] unroll
the quarters you just chuck the whole
thing out of her phone yeah yeah okay
well anyway we were talking about the
school year that got secondary school
what a wonderful man Wow wait a minute
kind of scary and cold so his childhood
dream was to like was for his school to
be like a palace well that looks like a
[ __ ] straight-up Mafia bosses palace
he renovated I don't want to be there as
a kid no but a lot of the kids were like
that shit's [ __ ] gaudy as hell yes
it's a Donald Trump [ __ ] are you trying
to make a Vegas casino what the [ __ ]
dude this is a schools are the primary
victim of graffiti babies everywhere
little kids go to elementary school well
they call the secondary suppose like
middle school maybe heist absolutely
middle school so this is like look like
yeah like the cracks in the in the
ceiling is so great so he's for sure
doing it for his own enjoyment like I
don't know if it's benefiting this
course not he's donating more computers
to the computer lab when I go back to my
old school it's very trashy in there I
would like to you wanted it fun boy you
want to spruce it up me make it so I
have somebody to massage my back one
doing his math test so that way I can be
relaxed while I'm trying to study like
yeah
and Versace and [ __ ] because it looks
like it and what are the what are the
books look like are they still shitty
absolutely they don't have any posted
they got a share so he was saying that
students will not need to visit places
like Versailles or the lube now no of
course has luxurious interiors that's
like don't go and it's like once you go
to Vegas you like you see essentially
reason yeah why go to France for that
[ __ ] don't even go to Egypt that's in
Luxor yeah just the same thing but it's
a black pyramid also saying that this
will create a good mood straightaway and
people who criticize are simply jealous
I am jealous he's right I'm sorry I'm
very good I wish I went to a school like
that I feel like I'll be like ultra cool
dude a billionaire saying like you're
just jealous is like the shittiest thing
of course we're telling the work not the
work I don't know I've never experienced
a bidet until I went to Asia like never
bunch of pad huh yeah no they're here no
people haven't but I don't know jealous
of Japanese public restrooms because
they don't have caca on the toilet seat
that's true and I'm like or gang
graffiti no but which is weird to me
like who's that dedicated that they
don't just write they block on the
toilet yeah and what are you doing is
that just razor blade so your face I was
just sitting right there this guy takes
a private jet everywhere I never have to
fly commercial West Was life he's like
you're just jealous I don't know he's
saying that nah he's become rich enough
to afford it he turned his old school
into I'm buoyant palace complete with
gilded walls marble floors and even a
water fountain well at least he did that
and didn't like he said I wanted to make
it look like it's all upside down in
here when I was a kid I was like that'd
be sick that won't go
created whatever is philanthropy is
philanthropist act this give him if it's
gonna benefit the kids room
I wonder he dresses like [ __ ] King
Louis - because if he likes ya he's
gonna walk around looking like a [ __ ]
pirate and [ __ ] Loki you should've just
have that like the school lunch and I
bet they still serving like old tater
tots said like court fees now they're
gonna surf caviar n [ __ ] did I say that
oh oh [ __ ] yeah I'll be dope if he hires
like real legit Cook's maids everything
and they get the whole experience
they're like well what about this what
about the Largey like I got an idea lose
the gold trim lose the marble all this
[ __ ] chandeliers candelabras everything
give that money to each family and kids
for the rest of the existences for him
it's not for the kids really see it's
for a little hit image yeah it's for a
little him I really am you know how
jaded we are though from like wealth is
like wound I went to Versailles and I
saw the house I was like that's it
really I think it's just you dude it's
really relatable when you went inside
the rooms right and you're looking at
the beds and in the layout you're just
like that's it inside
what are you talking about shit's crazy
where's that in French are you sure you
weren't in man francs huh yeah we have
to say look the beds are small I agree I
know there's no I was like why would I
want to come here this is pretty shitty
in here there's like secret passageways
to door I feel like I see mansions on
Zillow that that are more impressive
than that [ __ ] yeah you know that's like
there's no technology like everything
that's not jacuzzi knowing there's no
bathrooms I'm like where did this [ __ ]
they sat on their servants
yeah they shouldn't have servants mouths
parking [ __ ] was cool but I'm like I
would be bored out of my mind living
here dude isn't I think that the
European wealth in American wealth are
completely different because like
they'll get like a super small expensive
ass car we'll go out and get a Tesla oh
yeah we want everything bigger and
better is so like the matches that you
seal Zillow it's like yeah that'll be
like two managers over there do you
think it Ferraris out there and land
balls and [ __ ]
I don't live like they do because
they're Italian and stuff but but then
I'm like do they but are they as popular
as out here I don't know it's not as
encouraging as out here they don't they
have like crazy luxury tax whereas we
don't have it all right so we can ball
out a little bit harder than they can
Germany a lot of the taxi drivers and
stuff to drive beamers mm-hmm
before I German citizen to buy a damn
red they have to pay like a hundred or
hundred fifty percent tax I was in
Denmark in that that's how it was there
so the cars 50 G's you're paying like
100 to like 150 450g really you're
paying like look for another car base
with that that will maybe there'll be a
lifetime criminal I would be stealing so
much [ __ ] I'm not gonna work that hard
for it I'm just spill it I just couldn't
afford it I'm gonna drive it so you
somebody give it to me Alma steal it and
I'm not confrontational solid father
just did it so you're gonna car
dealership you're like hey Mouse Bronski
I'm not gonna steal yeah I can I take it
without to winner because I want to see
what it really feels like family here
and a car nice or you could be a
oil-rich Prince and then you could buy
it legitimate leave yeah cuz because I
get to I get to pick my family I didn't
know that was up hold the end of this
Chico
in the womb Joe no I'll send you to that
body next time when you come around
don't worry about it stop talking to me
mister I've been to the palace of
versaille water dump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]